what a great day
what a great day man look at this
picture okay also I want to show you
guys this real quick before we even get
started I saw this when I was driving
this morning in the car oh my I cannot
wait for every
soulsborne Creator to make a 35 minute
video about this picture
because you know it's gonna happen it's
like who is that riding torrent why does
the Earth tree look like this it's
already burned down I mean you know like
there's so much you can't wait for the
concert I just wanted to show you guys
that real quick bro I thought that was
so funny when I heard that this morning
man because I I woke up and I was just
like oh I'm gonna post my speedrun video
and then everyone in Discord is just
spamming me like Jake DLC DLC DLC and I
was like nah come on bro it's either
Queen America or Nicola or Saint Trina
or Rena
who knows who this is okay it's the
Haley tree is it the Haley tree sitting
in the middle of the ocean this is not
anywhere near that this could be a
completely different tree what does a
bunch of graves mean though when I see
these Graves here you know on like
radon's Battlefield and then the hill up
to Altus Plateau up to the capital city
you know those giant flags that are kind
of ghost-like that's what I think of or
yeah the big banners the big flags okay
here is the holiga tree
I look at the tree maybe if if the left
part broke off guys this tree does look
similar I don't know where y'all are
getting that it's not yo Zachary thank
you for the 10 super chat the Haley tree
is stated to be in the shadow of the
earth Tree in present lore this has to
be prior events when mikola found the
old tree before he used his body to fuel
the tree past events DLC it's most
likely the ER tree being wrapped or
being wrapped and strangled by the roots
of Godwin after we do the frenzied flame
ending the roots are squeezing Amber
left in the urge tree so you you all are
thinking it's a dream I'm along those
lines as well I mean all this could be
wrong since we're speculating from a
picture but this is fun to do just
remember nothing is certain until DLC
guys
guys here's here's what we need to do
right now because we're all spamming our
theories we're all going a little crazy
and that's totally fine and expected I
want a bunch of hearts in the chat
because we actually got DLC confirmed
man that made my heart so full
today dude
just so full look in the O of the logo
name
I see tree branches or like roots
wait is this the curse mark it is wait
what
it is look right here
ex ignore these branches going off
this little section right here and this
little section right here
that is that
don't know very very very similar this
would mean
at least from this logo that this this
DLC would have to do with Godwin as well
used to restore the fractured Elden ring
when brandished by the Elden Lord the
golden order was created by confining
destined death thus this new order will
be one of death restored should we watch
uh xylostorm's video did he just
released one
no sub desire if you haven't already
around 2 A.M
ring tweeted out this announcement yeah
two in the morning and let us walk A New
Path together an upcoming expansion for
Elden Ring's shadow of the archery is
currently in development we hope you
look forward to new adventures in the
lands between with an image to accompany
it and this image tells a lot right off
the bat we can see perhaps potentially
because of the DLC this is mikola the
character probably all along the DLC was
going to be about probably Nicola
identical to the scene in the cut scene
where Moog is carrying him true so that
is a very good thing to me because
mikola's story is by far the most
interesting in the game and deserves to
be continued I'm gonna go ahead and
throw it out there that there is a
98.7 chance
that this is mikola there's a chance
it's not
I'm over being like well it could it's
Nicola okay 98 percent
certainly but the fact that torrent is
with mikola here tells us two things
that this is either before or after the
events in the game or in another
dimension likely a dream which we'll
talk about it's a dream the tree is in a
completely different location than the
urge tree and the Haley tree I've never
seen land that looks like this maybe it
could be the lands after we become the
Lord of frenzied flame and burn
everything down I'm gonna go ahead and
say it's a dream that's that's what I
believe to be true that it that we are
in Nicola's dream in this situation I
think we're gonna touch the hand of the
body that's in the Cocoon and then we
can see what happened to mikola that's
what I believe is going to be the DLC
we're gonna see the entire timeline of
events leading up to Moog taking mikola
from the tree it seems like what we're
looking at here is actually another tree
wrapping around the archery in order to
strangle it which is why
um
I mean
yeah I can see it
Like A Parasite like a fungus since
physically it doesn't match up to the
lens between what I believe is it
doesn't match at all we're going to
enter mikola's dream and help him
establish the helic tree as I said I
totally agree it's a great Rune from
Nicola called the Great Rune of
abundance which may imply that we have
to kill Nicola or we receive it from him
in some other way but either way there
is I personally hope we don't kill
mikola I hope we talk with mikola and
get the full scope and story and he can
be like a companion to us or a questline
like Ronnie is
that's what I'm hoping for in terms of
the lore
I think we have absolutely no reason to
fight against mikola at all it literally
wouldn't make sense we are like just
trying to find out who he is but then if
you think about it like why is anything
attacking us why does Melania attack us
why like we know where Michaela's like
potential body is like it's in it's
amazing that we couldn't just like tell
her if we did know where it was right
but here's the difference and I brought
this up in my last mikola video from
like a month ago
there is a potential here
that mikola had good intentions going to
this situation right within this dream
like we're going to see all of the
events of the DLC he had good intentions
and when he realized that he couldn't
save his sister the ER tree was not
going to help him out at all the Haley
tree wasn't growing well he wasn't able
to maybe potentially fix his eternal
youth he sided with Moog and went down
that dark route
where we kill whatever's in that cocoon
does that make sense so while I do think
mikola is in the Cocoon that is not
mikola anymore
if you guys have seen berserk it's kind
of like uh what what's the guy's name
guy it's the mick Griffith thank you
it's Griffith it's it it's like the
exact same story as Griffith he was this
well-renowned everybody loved him and
when he realized that he couldn't
fulfill what he needed to do he became
this evil thing so that he could fulfill
at least some part of his dream I think
we will meet with mikola at least in
this point in the dream and get his true
intentions and then we'll realize he
went down a very dark path to try it and
he became the villain and it's it's been
widely known that Miyazaki is very
influenced by berserk and like a few
other animes as well nikola's dream
shadow of the earth tree would mean the
Halo tree in the entire story with that
we go from villain or we go from the
good guy to the villain and
unfortunately we might have to take down
nikola's alternate ego or not alternate
ego but he's
his what he becomes or of course as soon
as we get more information about it I
will be keeping you guys up to date here
on the channel you goddamn right Zion
subscribed overall I am I am very
subscribed I am curious of the comments
here here's the top one
I'm not this guy posted his Reddit post
never mind I'm not doing that I
completely see
how what Zio means by the tree being
strangled
do you guys see this now I guess this
right here would be the main trunk
the urge tree is splitting open
is this a face look at this
the archery is splitting open
and its sap is spilling out because of
it being strangled I definitely see that
now maybe God wins death root or death
blight
comes and strangles the tree that's a
possibility maybe this is Godwin
can we like see a face in here anywhere
is that Godwin
hold on
I don't know I can't see dude okay let's
take a step back let's take a step back
we're getting way too deep we're in
there like swimwear guys I am
beyond happy all I needed
was this All I Ever Need is just
confirmation that they're doing
something and they did it the hype is
now real here's what we need to
understand we are not going to know
anything until a trailer is shown and we
actually get the DLC okay
We're Not Gonna Know Jackal and that's
fine I'm okay with it as I've said a few
times I do not care what the DLC is I'm
just happy that we have it that's all I
want is the DLC confirmed DLC I don't
know when This is Gonna Come it could be
a year from now it could be a couple
months I don't care
whenever it comes out I'm gonna be here
playing it and having a good time man so
thank you all very very much again I'm
just happy my my heart is so full right
now it is so full and I hope you feel
the same way man
I'm so happy man